[Musik]
christian zeier ein mann im dilemma
zwischen profit orientierte wirtschaft
und klima aktivisten die den
kapitalismus am liebsten abschaffen
würden wenn es kühl dass die botschaft
von handys die über hunt christian zeier
chef des klimabewussten
wirtschaftsverbands swisscleantech was
für das bekommt ihnen intensiver damit
beschrieben männliche libido sisyphus
rollt das runde wieder auf
das ist jetzt aber typisches beispiel
zeigt dass thom walter kreissl
wenn man das sicher da wirkt auf dem
berg von der herstellung energie
verbraucht wurde zum beispiel kohlestrom
in china fabrikation in china in den
textilfabriken in vilich dampf ebenfalls
halb stellte das geht der missionen co2
und das kostet im moment nicht das
müssen andere ideale werte auf der
ganzen welt co2 preis das heißt wer co2
ausstoß konkret dürfen braucht wer kohle
verbraucht und damit co2 produziert da
müsst ihr für das zahlen eine weltweite
co2 abgabe noch völlig undenkbar
das thema mode und klima sowie so
unbeliebt billig kleiderläden wollen
nichts dazu sagen
und auch der chef des warenhauses loeb
hat nicht wirklich auf meine frage nach
einer co2 steuer gewartet die abgabe
wird daran du unheimlich der ausstellung
wie sollen wir das klimaziel erreichen
kein öl kohle bis transkript
hast du denn entfernt wird also hoffen
wir die nummer
es ist das klassische sprach- und ich
haben wieder mio ich begreife das sind
sie grundsätzlich erstmal eine seit ich
bin ich mir gar nicht dass loki schmidt
irgendetwas für andere
das ist prima einig das ist was ich
denke langheim überhaupt dieses modell
sein job ein schachspiel firmen seien
strategisch wichtige figuren die dame im
spiel aber sei die politik
christian zeier will ein gesetz dass
firmen und bürger zwingt ihr verhalten
zu ändern das revidierte co2 gesetz
kommt es durch werden benzin heizöl und
das fliegen teurer
es ist dezember die erste session nach
dem grünen band tsunamis vor die sind
immer noch ganz andere das co2 gesetz
wird erst im frühling verhandelt er aber
wer heute schon bei den neuen
parlamentsmitgliedern dafür agieren
und da kommt sein kontaktmann stefan
müller alt cvp nationalrat war doch
warten auf heidi z'graggen vormals cvp
regierungsrätin jetzt im ständerat
es sind bekannt aus funk und fernsehen
oder und mich komplett also im internet
vorstellen
ich muss mir vorstellen natürlich war
das ist wichtig bezirks projekt ist
wichtig dass zwischen sparen und diese
auch nur ihre kleine serie ja es braucht
aber wenig natürlich quatsch
[Musik]
hier greift sieht nächster versucht er
sucht jacqueline de quattro neue
fdp-nationalrätin die mitteparteien sind
gespalten in der klimafrage
[Musik]
richtige
das ist das projekt um ihr neues video
for climate sind einfach viel meiner
generation scheint mir finde das
wichtigste immer ein produktionsziel wo
wir in paris komplettiert sie also 20 50
netto nur quer
karten zwischen den prämien sind sie
anders dort tipps dank seiner guten job
mache ich wenn sie breit informieren
und wieder instand setzen abstimmen im r
20 cent das wird der verbreitete filme
weil das hilft dass es in die zellen
reagieren
wie grün aber sind die sie aus
verkleidet verpflichten sich die firmen
mit ihrer unterschrift das klimaziel zu
erreichen nein sagt er mir bewerbung für
das auch zum abonnieren können
garantieren dass das sehe ich überhaupt
nicht so neu gar getrennt der
verschiedenen firmen also muss ich
gerade aus deren argumentation zurück
und erhält das ist sehr froh dass wir
jetzt über 200 meter wieder 200 sagt ja
dass wir und das ist wichtig dass durch
machen mit allen eine herausforderung
und eine abnahme frage und auch einfach
journalisten gestellt werden
die aktion sei ein mittel zum zweck um
das co2 gesetz durchzubringen
in solcher bahnhofsnähe
der geschäftssitz von swisscleantech 350
firmen sind mitglied fast 300 mal
weniger aus beim konkurrenten economie
suisse dessen klimaziele viel
bescheidener sind heute steht dem
promovierten chemieingenieur eingang in
die höhle des löwen bevor die
reisebranche hat ihn zu einem vortrag
eingeladen briefing mit dem
pressesprecher in dem saal besetzt da wo
die schlechte botschaft überbringen
unter der kirche mit starcraft und die
rolle die die es einfach verrückt wie
ich die gesamte saison sind
ich weiß wie musik bücher der world of a
niveau liegen die flugreise bombogen der
u 23 punkte nur dass dir können
geld verdienen und und ihr seht ihr
wollt und wenn die maschinen wie die
küche positiv über froh dass die sind
gefangen im system
flugreisen überall und kreuzfahrtschiffe
beides co2 schleudern
hallo gibt ja schon da so ein thema mit
mit diesen schiffen mit mit den mit dem
co2-emission ausgabe und soja wie gehen
sie damit um über den co2 ausstoß
darüber habe ich hier keine
informationen
da werden sie aber zumal da gefragt dazu
ist das gar kein thema bei den kunden
kaum aus sicht des klimas müsste er ein
kreuzfahrtschiff verbot fordern
tut er aber nicht zu radikal also ich
bin mitglied im bett und ich will die
augen
ich bin ich bin will ich die kreter der
hoffnung
ich glaube ich glaube sie hat sehr viel
angst und das beglichen vertrauen und
und ich kann die kanzlei überzeugt
ich denke ich denke das ist schon
schwierig die situation
dr
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das hier ist gateway so sieht ihre
touristische attraktion in 100 jahren
aus was ist zu tun
raten sie den leuten langsamer zu reisen
länger zu reisen lokale zu reisen
nun man versucht das problem in der
schweiz zu lösen indem man ja jetzt eine
eine ticketabgabe flugtickets machen
will
finden sie auch gut nicht nein natürlich
nicht
die luftfahrt ist per se ein eingebautes
gewerbe braucht deshalb aus unserer
sicht auch ganz klar globale lösungen
wir sind kein ende wir sind am ende
wirtschaftlich wirtschaftsunternehmen
und man kann auch nicht nur jetzt an der
co2 vermeidung oder verhinderung
arbeiten wir wir engagieren uns für
menschenrechte wir engagieren uns alle
für kinderschutz alle für arbeitsschutz
für müllvermeidung und all diesen themen
wenn der klimawandel nicht funktioniert
haben wir probleme mit den
fluchtbewegungen dass wir sie direkt
betreffen liebe touristik wir haben
probleme mit der biodiversität dass wir
sie direkt betreffen die betulichkeit
wird wollte das thema nicht kleinreden
ich wollte das haus so stern vielen
herzlichen dank meine damen meine herren
[Musik]
was ist wir sind immer so ganz klappte
ganz sexy wo es mich denn zum
verweigerer entweder abstand regulieren
das ist ein bisserl ich persönlich bin
ja wenn die herde denn die bohne stöhnt
und sagen ja - hautau die ökonomische
realität
da muss ich denn jetzt will ich denke
nicht wirklich über die risiken oder
bieten und dass dann wenn die jedes
flugzeug stellen wie blöd und
klimapolitik setzt sektoren und
beflügelt weniger einfach aus hypothesen
sind das alles daran die das stranded
assets anlagen die ihren wert verlieren
wenn der co2 preis stark erhöht wird
[Musik]
also taten fähig aber dazu nicht
der 58 jährige lebt in ostermundigen
seine zwei kinder sind ausgezogen
an manchen wochenenden aber trifft man
sich zum sport
tochter flavia ist 23 und angehende
lehrerin silvan ist 22 beruflich einfach
er seinem vater nach studierte energie
und umwelttechnik benutzt so apple
risiko so muss der eigentlich beweisen
dass er bewusst sehr vorsichtig danke
natürlich würden sie an klima streiks
gehen sagen flavia und silvan die ganze
familie ist umweltpolitisch engagiert
ist jetzt gar nicht komplett schwarzen
alle und für mich ist schon ist nicht
einfach sich gedanken machen wie viel
verantwortung
die generation also was wir schon immer
so gemacht
aber ich andresky kann man sagen also
spd die jetzt auf die straße in form von
bewegung
heute sind sie seine hoffnungsträger
frühe arbeit hat sich christian zeier
schwer mit dem thema familienplanung hat
klima dann spielt wieder überlegen
wirklich hinter natürlich die die umma
prozent tirol und das ist nicht einfach
entscheide ich sie für mich das ist also
wenden kann
vor zehn jahren sanierte er sein haus
damals eines der modernsten im
umweltbereich müllsack erhöhte so als
vorzeige hus vieles von dem wo wir doch
macht spannend ist es recht standort
damals arbeitete er als energieberater
interessenten führte er durch sein
vorzeige heim und kam so zu neuen
aufträgen dusche mit klarem wasser das
sich so wie er als zusatz dass ich nicht
geld sondern das ist kühl und
energieexperte sagte lüth wo das halt
machen stiegen aus dem leben wie sie
jetzt bis 20.50 dass sie komplett sekte
wichtigsten die dreiecke vor der wald
und das wäre die renoviert bis 50 euro
blieben schwellenländer brauchen die
ganze transport von öl ab dass ich
einfach die augen streuen wenn man sagen
gebt mir ja denn ich das machen soll
aber es gibt mir genau andere ökonomen
und erich experte oder andere sage das
aber wird man wird sehen was passiert
also die hat nichts gefehlt oelrich
weltwirtschaft sei aber von heute auf
morgen sei der ausstieg schon nicht
möglich
seine frau ist teamleiterin bei der
spitex das paar politisiert für die sp
im gemeinderat ökohaus haut hätten
schulkollegen früher gesagt
der jogger und zu herrschen hier so
seien sie sportlicher leiter der
menschen und der flauen abermals das ist
das no-go
du hast im schulhaus
[Musik]
dass er seine überzeugung lebt weil sich
unterdessen dass er bei swiss cleantech
aber auch schwierige zeiten durchmachte
erfahre ich am 10 jahres jubiläum sein
verhältnis zum gründer ist gespalten
nick beglinger verließ den verband vor
vier jahren
er galt als anfang der rede und der
jetzt rasch nicholas carr und trainieren
und so die heimische zum teil heftig
doch dank heute ich dann nicht so eine
spitzel ist absoluter das machwerk also
eben wenig wie vor auf der bühne zeitung
das abfilmen und mindestens so lange bis
sie da haben sie kam es nicht zu uns wir
schon relativ hell wie sagt man ihnen an
seiner seite
das selber gründe haben
geboren und ich ausdrücken das ist
mandatsbasis die jugendlichen
geschrieben und rechnet mit
und wenn ich die harten stoffe was ich
das ziel 2014
jetzt aber mit 350 firmen hätten sie
immer noch zu wenig mitglieder nach wie
vor enorm beliebt ist das ist ganz klar
wir stoßen die herausforderungen einer
also das ist dokumentiert von der person
ich mache da noch geld aus firmen und
schweizer firmen mitglieder
wir bestehen zu können es ist jetzt aber
ich kann nicht hat hobbits linie mit dem
stimmen
wie aber sieht die finanzielle zukunft
des verbandes aus das meiste geld kommt
von stiftungen im oman themen
vierjahresvertrag
wo jetzt muss läuft wo man jetzt
diskutieren ist irgendwie das wetter gut
das ja und auch sie schaffen das die
stiftung bezahlt das ist dankbar dass
das was gibt's ohne wissen müsste größer
nun ich habe jeder ja natürlich dass ich
ganz klar das ganze worden was das heißt
eben eine glückliche momente zum
jubiläum ist wichtig bewusst dass vieles
auf dem spiel
zehnmal mehr mitglieder bräuchte der
verband um selbst raten zu sein
die kehrseite des grünen tsunami
[Musik]
woher aber wird es das bedingungslose
engagement des 58-jährigen aufgewachsen
ist er in luzern
seine mutter habe ihn stark geprägt die
wand sei stolz ein 90 jahre alt früher
war sie ärztin
sie unterrichtete aber auch an schulen
zum thema umwelt und gesundheit in den
1960 er jahren war sie alarmiert
jährlich krepieren in unseren gewässern
tausende von fischen zu hunderten münden
abwasser geräten und kloaken in den see
und diskutiert wurde also mit dem wasser
läuft es ganz schlecht und der
konsumismus was ich da breit gemacht
hält das ist an die 50er jahre in der
sache und den über 6 mio da ich hab's
halt das große fragezeichen sind macht
wurde von der wissenschaft der herr und
die hängt das und das fasziniert so die
händler so früh wie 70
daneben ist der katalysator und phosphat
ihm verboten wo das ist ja ganz figur
das ja das ist ja das was die
trügerische oder immer wenn wir alles
gemacht hat ich habe bis passiert aber
mehr gewinn gemacht das ist oder dass
man muss sagen man hätte sie viel von
denen geschichte wo mitgemacht enthält
liegt in dem das man einfach nur wenige
brutalität clara aktion beispiel die
bucht relativ viel energie
der zehnjährige christian barth seinen
lehrer einen vortrag halten zu dürfen
titel unser land ist in gefahr es kann
sein dass wir in 20 jahren nur noch mit
der gasmaske in die stadt gehen können
die ölheizungen autos täglich und
verbieten verbrauchen unsere luft und
verpassten sie hätte wirklich angespannt
offensichtlich aber ich habe das nicht
gemerkt ich habe dann sind das
interpretiert herzlich besorgen ist auf
ihn übertragen ich gab es schon ja also
wenn ich der vortrag lese denke ich ja
deutsch also schon mal material also
irgendwo mal es macht mir damalige
schwarz küste lagert sie dann in deiner
wahl
ja das wird jetzt also schon ich sehr
schwierige frage und es waren oft war
groß sind habe ich spüre großmutter
freude kann würde ich größter was oft zu
hoch und so oder so
das ist für mich das schlimmste
was mir gemacht und zwei monate später
sonntagabend danke dass du nazis für das
was die sache zu besprechen
der verband scheint vorerst gerettet
eine stiftung hat eine million in
aussicht gestellt aber nur unter klaren
auflagen absprache mit seinem vize
präsidentin von der fdp zwischen den
anstrengungen die situation auf jeden
fall mein ich bin schockiert
wenn es so kommen würde das ist so
obwohl stelle des handwerks machen
trina lieferwagen ausbauen mit der
werkstatt und nach der pflicht das war
nur cool
aber das ist im moment wirklich nicht im
fokus für mich und ich bin überzeugt
dass wir eine nachhaltige wirtschaft da
will ich mich einsetzen für das ist ganz
klar nein nein sicher nicht